good morning believe nation my name is
Evan Carmichael my one word is believe
but I believe that entrepreneurs will
solve all of the world's major problems
so to help you in your journey today's
message is take action over to you Mel
Robbins one night Chris had gone to bed
I've been struggling struggling
struggling we still had all the same
problems I we started lean on the house
still facing bankruptcy still fighting
like crazy I was still unemployed
he still they still haven't figured out
like the solution yet for the business
and I was about to turn off the TV and
there on the TV there was this rocket
launching and I thought oh my gosh is it
I am going to launch myself out of bed
like a rocket ship like NASA right here
and launch me out of that bed and I'm
going to move so fast that I don't think
I'm gonna beat my brain now here's a
really interesting point I talked a lot
about your instincts and inner wisdom
and we can get into this a little bit
later but a lot of us talk about the
fact that you have a gut feeling but
what all this research that I've done
for the book and all the speaking that I
do what I've discovered that's
fascinating is actually when you set
goals when you have an intention on
something that you want to change about
your life your brain helps you what it
does is it opens up a checklist and then
your brain goes to work trying to remind
you yeah of that intention that you said
and it's really important to develop the
skill and I say that word purposefully
the skill of knowing how to hear that
inner wisdom and that intention kicking
in and leaning into it quickly so for me
my brain saying that's it right there
move as fast as a rocket Mel I wanted to
change my life and I think most people
that are miserable or that are that are
really like dying to be great and dying
to have more
we want to change we want to live a
better life we want to create more for
our families we want to be happier
the desire is there again it's about how
do you go from knowledge to action so
the first thing in the story that's
important is realizing that the answer
was in me and my mind was telling me pay
attention could have also been a bourbon
and how does that night anyway
the next morning the alarm goes off and
I pretended NASA was there
it's a stupidest story I literally went
five four three two one accounted out
loud and then I stood up and I'll never
forget standing there in my bedroom it
was dark it was cold it was winter in
Boston and for the first time in three
months I had beaten my habit of hitting
the snooze button I couldn't believe it
and I thought wait a minute counting
backwards that is the dumbest thing I've
ever heard in my entire life well the
next morning I used it again and it
worked the next morning I used it again
and it worked the next morning I used it
again and it worked and then I started
to notice something really interesting
there were moments all day long all day
long just like that five-second moment
in bed where I knew knowledge what I
should do and if I didn't move within
five seconds my brain would step in and
talk me out of it every human being has
a five-second window might even be
shorter for you you have about a
five-second window in which you can move
from idea to action before your brain
kicks into full gear and sabotages any
change in behavior because remember your
brain is wired to stop you from doing
things that are uncomfortable or
uncertain or scary it's your job to
learn how to move from those ideas that
could change everything into acting on
thinking action is the cure-all taking
action solves all the problems that
you're going through whatever problem
you have whatever thing is in front of
you whatever obstacle is there
it seems unsurmountable it it's not
going to get fixed by just sitting and
complaining and wallowing and feeling
sorry for yourself it happens I'm taking
action as soon as you can move from that
place of being unhappy and desperate and
sorry for yourself to how do I solve
this who do I need to contact to help me
how can I use the resources I have to
fix this as soon as you start moving to
that land that's when you start to make
progress taking action is the cure-all
this will happen so many times to
entrepreneurs not even just with
problems but with ideas in general how
often do you get an idea for something
that you want to do and then you say
tomorrow I'm going to do it and then
tomorrow coming you don't do it how many
times what happens that happens over and
over and over and over and against the
human condition such as entrepreneurs we
have these things these ambitions these
drives that we set for ourselves and
then we don't follow through on the best
way to start on that idea you have is to
take action do something immediately as
soon as you set a goal I want to start a
YouTube channel great what are you gonna
do on your YouTube channel I want to
interview people amazing today set up
your YouTube channel and send out ten
emails to people to ask them for
interviews people that you know people
who you think will say yes when you
commit to somebody else you're much more
likely to follow through and what
happens is perfection becomes the enemy
of action you want to make it perfect
and because you make it perfect it gets
more and more and more and more and more
complex and complexion is the enemy of
execution because you build it up to be
this big thing this big scary thing that
asks me perfect you don't do anything
before I set up my youtube channel I
need to have the perfect channel art I
need to have the right thumbnails and I
need to know what my script is going to
be and I need to know my intro an opener
or anything here all of these things
that you need to have to make a perfect
video because it because this big thing
you don't do anything about it and then
the next day you wake up and it's gone
oops as soon as you set a goal for
yourself I want to go and do this the
best next thing you can do is take some
form of immediate action and ideally
commit to somebody else
whether it's a friend whether it's a
potential customer whether you're
sending emails out whether it's your
family whether it's a neighbor commit to
somebody else
because when you do that you're much
more likely to follow through because
you won't let them down
you'll let yourself down all the time
you let yourself down every morning when
you wake up and hit the snooze button
you're letting yourself down the first
thing you do in the morning is let
yourself down you set a goal boom I let
myself down you let yourself down all
the time but you won't let other people
down nearly as much so taking immediate
action and then follow through with
somebody else so that you don't let
yourself and then down so the question
today today is I'm curious what is one
big goal you have and one action you're
going to take today not tomorrow right
now right after posting this comment
you're going to go take action
immediately leave it down the comments
below really curious to find out I also
want to give a quick shout out to Julia
from inside the jewel box calm Julia
thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book your one word I really really
really appreciate the support and I hope
you're enjoying the read thank you guys
again for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
and we'll see you guys again tomorrow
morning for another shot of espresso
or spray so give me go
take action whatever you want to do
whatever you're thinking about it you
will not get it until you take action
make that move
make it a small step if you want a house
go get a rug you know I mean if you want
a new car go get some car freshener take
action make this thing happen for you
and it will happen action action action
you know one thing that uh you know I
can really attribute to every failure in
my life um whether it be personal
financial in any kind of way business
whatever it's because of a lack of my
attempt to take action I did not take
action and it kind of changed once I got
the fact that action is the key um it
changed my life you have to actually
show up every day and inch yourself
forward toward these dreams and not only
show up every day and once in a while
into yourself I mean every day you have
to actually take an action that moves
you forward not just research not just
thinking look the power of an intention
is great but without any initiative it's
dead right a dream is great but without
any movement it's dead you have to be
moving towards every day you can send an
email every day you can make a call
every day you can write something every
day you can create something every day
you can contribute something every day
but it has to be daily otherwise it will
never become actualized and the highest
performers in the world didn't get there
because they were lucky they worked at
it longer than everyone else they had a
better work ethic and it's not that they
necessarily always worked harder they
work smarter because they were doing the
research they were taking the time to
visualize how they would be distinct
different how they would survive the
tough times they really kept at it keep
every single day momentum going and if
you don't do that
there's no chance one of the functions
of belief is taking action we did a
survey of about 2,000 top entrepreneurs
and we noticed that one of the things
that people who win in that world have
is a bias for action if they have an
inspiration they act on it I mean how
many of you have ever had a great idea
talked about it thought about it didn't
do it then someone else did it was
successful and you went on I should have
done that maybe it was by that piece of
property because all that we all have
that piece of property we wish we'd
bought you know anyway so we're going to
be looking at the idea that taking
action is part of Law of Attraction so a
lot of people thinking just sit in your
room
meditate visualize having the perfect
car the perfect house the perfect
relationship and then it'll kind of just
come to you and I always say unless you
live at the bottom of the hill where
there's a road probably not going to be
a Cadillac show up in your living room
right so think about this the last six
letters of the word attraction spell
what a cpio in action now there's two
kinds of actions that are critical
there's obvious actions if you want a
certain kind of car you should go down
and test drive it you should find out
how much it costs you should see what it
costs to maintain it you should go you
know spend I like to test drive a car
three or four times go down to the
dealer take a camera stick my head out
the window say take a picture of me I'll
be back to buy it put it up on my
refrigerator look at it every day
eventually you know those kind of things
produce car all right saving for it and
so forth but there are also things
called inspired actions all of a sudden
you get an inspiration to do something
and you didn't know what it was you
don't have a sense of like how's this
rationally going to make sense for me to
move forward in my life
I'll give you an example a friend of
mine dr. Ignatius Piazza graduates
chiropractic school he wants to move to
Monterrey near Pebble Beach where the
golf course is and he gets there and he
says to the local Chiropractic
Association like to join you or like you
to help me get my practice started and
they said we don't need any more
chiropractors we have one chiropractor
for every eight people in this area too
many now he could have said okay let the
external reality control his internal
experience but he didn't do that
he said I'm going to think about this
and visualize it and believe in it and
something will come that I will do and
what came to him to do was to take six
months before he opened his office and
put a pin where he wanted his office and
then concentric circles
on every door in every neighborhood
saying hi I'm a new doctor in town could
I ask you a few questions you know I'm
starting this practice should I open
from 5:00 to 9:00 in the morning and of
course should I be open from 5:00 until
9:00 at night for people who have
nine-to-five jobs which would be better
should I advertise in this paper or that
paper should I call it Ignatius Piazza
chiropractic or chiropractic West then
his last question was the five an open
house would you like to receive an
invitation they said yes he wrote it
down now over six months he knocked on
12500 doors talked to 6500 people and
gathered over 4,000 names of people who
said yes I'd like an invitation to your
open house now when he opened his office
six months later in a town that did not
need another chiropractor according to
the professionals his first month in
practice he netted seventy two thousand
dollars in his first year in practice
his gross income was over a million
dollars I was giving a talk to mention
this story just about five years ago and
this happened about 25 years ago someone
said he knocked on my door and he left
his card and two years later I needed
the chiropractor and I called him
because we work with people we know
we've had an experience with right so he
trusted his intuition he took action on
it other people would say oh guess I
can't have what I want you got to be
willing to take the action